hey everybody it's Mike for you here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
guess what I'm back with another
compliance tip of the week this week
we're talking about cmmccontrol m a DOT
[Music]
l2-3.7.6 supervise the maintenance
activities of Maintenance Personnel
without required access authorization
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all of this
cmmc dfars and nist SP 10171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got great news for
you you found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance hero uh let's jump
into it so now this one I love say hey
look especially in manufacturing we've
gotten maintenance people okay and they
may not even be a formal employee they
could be outsourced at the end of the
day you're required to escort visitors
at all times however a maintenance
person is therefore not a random visitor
they may have been given facility access
every situation is different and believe
me there's some very interesting
thoughts about contractors maintenance
people and how they are different from a
visitor I just realized that's a massive
run-on sentence that literally goes for
like seven lines which is probably why I
couldn't read it straight
but I don't have time to rewrite it so
all right there you go
it's the best I can do for an example
honestly I mean anyway if you've got
questions on that I would invite you to
give us a call because let me tell you
it's not super simple let me tell you
it's not super simple reading this this
is not super simple to read at all as a
matter of fact actually I'd probably say
this is above a third grade read level
which has maximized my personal
capability to read I was elected to lead
not to read
totally stole that if you know where
comment below most importantly you've
got to supervise these people they
should not in most cases be authorized
to view or handle cui and when they are
in the building there needs to be a
heightened sense of alert and monitoring
of their activities to dig in more let's
find out what the assessors want to see
on this one
all right determinative maintenance
Personnel without required access
authorization and supervised during
maintenance activities uh
yeah all cuis physically protected from
access by maintenance Personnel without
required access authorization hey look
if the maintenance guy doesn't have
access to cui because it's in a lock
computer or in a key locked filing
drawer they won't be able to get to it
you just have to show and assessor that
that's really kind of what it boils down
to right examples are it use in cyber
security policy visitor escort policy
contractor policy all those are
different kinds of policies you can have
in place to prove what they're looking
for on the assessment front and
the good news for you
is I will be doing your consultation
because my jokes are terrible and um and
there are better people for that but uh
what I do do is hear it on call besides
poorly reading teleprompters is we work
with defense contractors just like you
who have had this DeForest nist itar and
cmmc compliance stuff dropped in their
laps like a seagull on a sunny day hey
look it could be really boring like I
could sit in front of like a big boom
stand and I could sit there and
just like be really serious about this
and talk about it
like it's life or death
yuck
I'd rather just teach you how to level
up and be a proper on call compliance
hero for your company all right really
and you know what along the way we'll
all have a couple laughs where it's me
one of my Consultants all right we
always like to have a good time and make
this stuff not so incredibly terrible
all right eliminating gaps gray areas
and getting this solved all while
showing you how to leverage compliance
is your super secret weapon to land more
Defense work with higher profit margins
and maybe even a few jokes now that's
what becoming an on-call compliance hero
can do for you if you're looking for
more help getting compliant our
compliance experts are always on call
for you visit cmmc compliancecrets.com
why is the cmmc compliance Secrets
because the secret is it's not that hard
if you got the right team on your side
all right or check out the bio below for
links to get help right now love the
content we're putting out here for you
help us out with a big thumbs up on that
like button or even better smash the
Subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliances rolled out I'm calling you
out by the way right now you're not
subscribed I see you you're not
subscribed listen your mouse only has to
move from here to there and you're
subscribing look at that dude you're
gonna get to see me whenever I put out
new content and that's so awesome thank
you makes my day doesn't just make my
day by the way makes our entire team's
day all right
um I think I talked yesterday about the
gong anyway I digress until the next
compliance that my friends stay safe and
secure out there hit us in the comments
below to let us know what you'd like to
know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next one
[Music]
foreign